وسط اجواء مشحونه يخيم عليها كساد اقتصادي
بحلول الخامس من هذا الشهر حاول رئيس مجلس
النواب تهدئه المعارضين للصفقه من داخل
حزبه الجمهوري
سنحقق الليله ما لم يتحقق من قبل اذ اننا
سنمنح امريكا املا ونصوت على اكبر عمليه
ادخار في تاريخ امريكا يتجاوز التريليون
اي دولار
بالنسبه للديمقراطيين فان ذلك الادخار جاء
على حساب الفقراء وعلى حساب قيم الحزب لكن
ذلك لن يمنعهم من دعم الصفقه على علتها
منذ البدايه اوضح النواب الديمقراطي انهم
لن يسمحوا للمتطرفين الجمهوريين بعاقتنا
عن سداد الديوننا وبتدمير اقتصادنا بكساد
مدمر للوظائف
خلافات الحزبين حول رفع سقف الدين كانت
خلافات اقتصاديه وسياسيه بابقاء كل طرف
نعيما على الوفاء بالالتزامات الماليه
واخرى على مواعيد الاستحقاقات الانتخابيه
اعتقد انه حل وسط وكان على الطرفين تقديم
تنازلات لكن بيضا كان المستفيد الاكبر
بضمانه رفع سقف الديون لعامين وحفاضه على
كل مكتسباته التشريعيه في هذه الاثناء
يواجه رئيس مجلس النواب انتفاضه منظمه من
الجناح المتشدد في حزبه بل تهديدات
بازاحته من منصبه من مفارقات الجدل حول
مشروع القانون الجديد بروز تحالفات جديده
من قبيل وحده بين اقصى اليمين الجمهوري
واقصى اليسار الديمقراطي في معارضته
وتحالف اخر بين معتدلي الحزبين لانقاذه
تجنبا
لكارثه اقتصاديه
وسياسيه غير مسبوقه محمد العلمي الجزيره
من مقر الكونجرس واشنطن